شكرا لزميلنا نادين خماش اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه المستمره على
شاشه العربيه ومنصاتها على شبكات التواصل
الازمه السودانيه المستمره في يومها
الحادي عشر الهدنه المعلنه منذ ليله
الاثنين الى ثلثال لمده اثنتين وسبعين
ساعه تعرضت للخرق وسط استمرار التهم بين
طرفي النزاع اللذين يبدوان مصرين على
مواصله القتال خوفا من تقدم طرف على اخر
او استغلالا لفرصه الهدنه لاعاده الانتشار
لعبه الشطرنج هذه على رقعه السودان
الشاسعه لا تراعي بالضروره اوضاع
السودانيين الهاربين من النار والدمار وفي
هذا السياق طلب مسؤول سياسات الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع بالالتزام بالهدنه التي
اعلناها لمده 72 ساعه بشكل كامل وقال
بوريل في تغ ريده له على تويتر ان الهدف
هو التوصل لوقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
واقامه ممرات انسانيه لحمايه مدنيين
وفي سباق تبادل الاتهامات اصدر الجيش
السوداني بيانا شجب من خلاله الخروقات
العديده التي اقترفها الدعم السريع للهدنه
بحسب تعبير حيث قال الجيش السوداني ان
مجموعات الدعم السريع تواصل تحركاتها داخل
وخارج الخرطوم رغم الهدنه واكد الجيش رصده
لتحركات لارتال عسكريه متجهه من غرب
السودان الى الخرطوم بالاضافه الى محاولات
من الدعم السريع السيطره على مصفى الجيل
للتحكم بالوقود كما اضاف الجيش في بيانه
ان الدعم السريع يحاول استغلال الهدنه
لانقاذ موقفه العملياتي المتدهور حيث نشر
قناصه في الخرطوم وولايات اخرى اكد الجيش
السوداني على احتفاضه بالحق في التعامل مع
خروقات الدعم السريعي للهدنه
قوات الدعم السريع مشاهدينا كانت قد اتهمت
في وقت مبكر اليوم قوات الجيش السوداني
باستهداف مواقعها قرب القصر الجمهوري
بالخرطوم ما يعد حسب ما ذكرته قوات الدعم
انتهاكا للهدنه المعلنه لتنتين وسبعين
ساعه مؤكده ان القصف العشوائي للجيش يهدد
حياه المدنيين ورعاي الدول الاجنبيه في
الخرطوم قوات الدعم السريع اشارت في
بيانها الى ان كسر شروط الهدنه المعلنه
يؤكد وجود اكثر من مركز قرار داخل قياده
القوات المسلحه
وبعد ساعات من سريان هدره لمده ثلاثه ايام
بوساطه سعوديه امريكيه افاد مراسل العربيه
ان دوي الاسلحه الثقيله عاد ليسمع في ام
درمان وفي محيط القصر بالخرطوم بحسب شهود
عيان هناك تحليق للطيران وضرب للمدفعيه
وسماع لاصوات اشتباكات متقطعه باسلحه
خفيفه
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر حصيره لها جراء الاشتباكات اعلنت
نقابه اطباء السودان ارتفاع اعداد الوفيات
من المدنيين لاكثر من 290 حاله وفاه ونحو
1700 حاله اصابه وقالت اللجنه ايضا ان هذه
الاعداد مرشحه للزياده لعدم قدره النقابه
على الوصول الى المستشفيات لصعوبه التنقل
والوضع الامني في البلاد
علاقه صداقه وتحالف جمعت الفريق اول محمد
حمدان دقلو حمدتي وعبد الفتاح البرهان
بدات منذ نحو 20 عاما عندما قاتل الطرفان
في خندق واحد في معارك دارفور وازدادت هذه
العلاقه متانه مع التطورات السياسيه في
السودان وصولا الى اسقاط حكم البشير لكن
لا شيء ثابتا في السياسه فاصدقاء الامس
تحولوا لاعداء اليوم وانتهت العلاقه
بمعارك طاحنه بين الطرفين
وصلاح متي الى ولايه نهر النيل زياره خاصه
الى منزل البرهان استقبال بحفاوه ونقاش
حميمي حول مستقبل السودان
هذه الصور كانت قبل نحو عام حليفه الامس
صراع عدوين فلا شيء ثابت بالسياسه
[موسيقى]
قبل نحو 20 عاما كان اللقاء الاول بين
قطبي الصراع في السودان التقح متي
والبرهان في دارفور قاتلا في خندق واحد
بعد 12 عاما تشاؤل اقدار ان يتقاطع طريقان
الرجلين مجددا
ويتفقا على ارسال قوات مشتركه من الدعم
السريع والجيش للمشاركه مع قوات التحالف
في اليمن كل
الغروب رجل واحد
تعززت العلاقه بين احمد والبرهان لتصل في
العام 2019 الى دعم الحراك الشعبي للاطاحه
بحكم البشير
لوحدتنا كلنا قلنا الكلام ده قلنا قوتنا
في وحدتنا وما زلنا بنقول الكلام ده في كل
يوم احنا قوتنا في وحدتنا نحن وحدتنا
وتماسكنا هي
وحده السودان
واليوم ينفرط عقد التحالف بين حمدتي
والبرهان
فالسودان كاي سفينه لا يمكن ان يقودها
قبطان
تتفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه وتزداد سوءا في
السودان حيث نفذت مواد غذائيه اساسيه من
متاجر العاصمه الخرطوم في ظل الاشتباكات
التي عمتنا سودانيه اخرى بعد 11 يوما بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في وقت ارتفعت
اسعار المواد المتوفره على قلتها وفق شهود
عيان ورغم توقف معظم محطات الوقود عن
العمل في مدينه ام درمان لا زالت طوابير
السيارات تطول وتطول
عايزين نمرق نمشي الولايات ما قادرين ما
لاقين بنزين وحتى ناس المواصلات نعم
التجربه بتاع مواصلات تقول لنا احنا مثلا
عايزين تذكره او كده
التذكره غاليه جدا يعني التذاكر بخمسه
الفقه ب 150 الف حتى لو لقينا دكان فاتح
هنا ما بنقدر نجيب منه حاجه لانه
في استغلال يعني حتى لو الباكو بتاع
الدقيقه الليله ب 8000 هيديك له قريبا من
محل
كان قلت انت مستقل عشان كده نحن اي حاجه
تقطع مني انا
حاصله يعني بكل جهاد لا كهرباء ولا مويه
يمكن يشد عليه هنا والخبز اهو زي ما انت
شايف
اربعين دقيقه بين اربعين الى 60 دقيقه
في هذا السياق توقفت شركه ميرسي
الدنماركيه اكبر ناقله بحريه للحاويات
توقفت عن اخذ اي حجوزات جديده للبضائع في
السودان بسبب الاشتباكات ووفق البيان فان
شركه الشحن البحريه
العملاقه
تتابع التطورات في السودان عن كثب وبناء
عليه علقت استلامه اي بضائع من السودان
ريثما يتحسن الوضع ويعود الاستقرار الى
سلسله التوريد في البلاد
ينضم الينا من لندن مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للتنميه والعون الانساني الصادق محمد احمد
سيد الصادق مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
المباشره للعربيه دعني ابدا معك مما ذكرته
قبل قليل اهلا وسهلا الصحه العالميه قالت
بان هناك خطر بيولوجي كبير بعد السيطره
احد طرفي النزاع بالسودان على مختبر ما
الذي يعني هذا ما هو المختبر ايضا حتى
المقصود ان كانت لديكم اي معلومات حول هذا
الامر
وزاره الصحه
وكان متوقع هذا في ظل هذه الفوضى الحاصله
حاليا وسيطره هذه
الميليشيات على بعض المناطق في في وسط
الخرطوم فيخشى من ان
يتم استغلالها
تسرب يؤدي ايضا الى المزيد من المخاطر هذا
يدخل في ضمن من ضمن سلسله
المخاطر التي تحيط بالشعب السوداني في هذه
الفتره العصيبه من هناك كارثه بيئيه ايضا
محتمله وهي ناتجه من انتشار الجسد على
الشوارع ايضا هذه الان لم يتم انتشار عدد
كبير جدا من الجثث ايضا هذا يحدد بكارسه
بيئيه محتمله
ما هي هذه الكارثه المحتمله سيد الصادق ما
هو السيناريو الاكثر سوءا استمرت هذه
الجثث ملقاه على يعني قارعه الطريق في
الخرطوم تحديدا انت كما تعلم ويعلم
المشاهدين ان عدم تحلل الجثث في الشوارع
واختلاطها ايضا بمصادر المياه وان تختلف
الامطار خصوصا ان هذه هي فتره فتره التوقع
هطول الامطار ايضا في المنطقه وبالتالي
يمكن ان يؤدي الى انتشار امراض واوبئه قد
تنقل المزيد من الامراض ايضا كل ذلك يلقي
كبير جدا على الجهات الصحيه في البلاد
وايضا على المنظمات العامله في المجال
الصحي
ويندر ايضا
ان يكون هناك تفشي الامراض قد يتطلب
علاجها ايضا المزيد الجهود والتقضي على
عدد ايضا من
المواطنين جراء انتشار هذه الاوبئه
المتوقعه طيب فيما يخص ايضا حتى الاوضاع
المعيشيه ربما سمعت قبل قليل الى
الخبر البيان الذي نشرته شركه دنماركيه
والتي قالت بانها توقفت عن اخذ حجوزات
يعني بضائع تنقل الى السودان ما الذي يعني
هذا بالنسبه للوضع اساسا
الانساني الوضع المعيشي الصعب في السودان
من قبل شركه الشحن شركات النقل الكبرى في
العالم ياتي ضمن سلسله من
الاجراءات التي تبعتها ابتداء من المنظمات
الدوليه التي علقت عملها في السودان مرورا
باجلاء البحثات الدبلوماسيه لرعاياها
الموجودين في بلاد وهذا يعطيهم ضمن هذه
السلسله من المخالفه فيها الشركات من
الخساره ومن ان يكون هناك اعتداء ايضا على
ربما يتوقعون ان يكون هناك اطلاع على قطاق
السفن هم يتوقعون
وايضا
العمليات قد ايضا يكون هذا سبب اخر لتعليق
عمل هذه الشركات فالعمل على الارض من نقل
الشحنات وانتقال الشاحنات الاخر في هذه
الفتره يتعرض للكثير من
الصعوبات وبالتالي هذا ياتي في سياق
التحركات المختلفه للجهات المختلفه سواء
كانت الدول او شركات او
ساتحدث معك عن عن هذه التحركات والى اي
مدى هناك على الارض والى اي مدى هناك
بدائل لكن اشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل اسفل
الشاشه اذا ولايه كردفان او شمال كردفان
المشاهدين تعلن فرض حظر جزئي ليلا حظر
تجوال جزئي ليلا اذا ولايه شمال كردفان
تعلن فرض حظر
للتجوال
جزئيا بشكل جزئي ليلا ولايه شمال كردفان
اذن مشاهدينا هذا هو التطور الجديد في
السودان الان
وربما هي احد تبعات يعني ما يحدث من
تصاعدا في المشهد السوداني بشكل مستمر
الولايه ولايه شمال كردوفان كردوفان تعلن
فرض حظر تجوال جزئي ليلا هذه هي اخر
الاخبار العاجله من السودان كما نشاهدها
اسفل الشاشه
اعود اليك مره اخرى سيد
الصادق كنا نتحدث واياك قبل قليل عن يعني
ما نقلته هذه الشركه
الدنماركيه وتعليق العمل ايضا كذلك نقل
البضائع والحجوزات الى السودان مع توقفها
ومع توقف ايضا بعض المنظمات الاغاثيه
والانسانيه ايضا كذلك وايضا بعض الشركات
التي ستحدث هذه الشركه الدنماركيه ما هو
البديل اليوم
للسودان لتلقي هذه البضائع ايضا او المواد
الغذائيه ودخولها الى السودان
هناك صعوبات في النقل
البريجوار ربما كان هذا هو سيكون البديل
هو نقل البري بين السودان ودول الجوار
ولنقل البضائع ولكن دعنا على الخبر الذي
اورثته قبل قليل من عمليه
يجب ان يتم هذا قبل مده في جميع ان انا
اعتقد يجب ان تعدن الحكومه عن
فرض حظر التجوال واعلان حاله الطوارئ وذلك
لمحاوله السيطره على الاوضاع حتى لا تخلط
من يدها لا اعتقد لماذا تاخر ذلك خصوصا
اننا نعلم انه في الفتره الماضيه
الدعم السريع استغلت الهدنه في مواد في
تموينها من الاسلحه من من الخارج وكذلك
مثبت في تقارير المخابرات العسكريه حيث
هبطت الطائره في المنطقه الحدوديه في
القادمه من ليبيا وتم انزالها على في
قاعده شفروليه الصحراء بين السودان وليبيا
وتلقتها
انا اعتقد انه كان يجب ان يكون هناك حظر
للتجوال وفرض الحال الطوارئ حتى يتم
السيطره على مثل هذه
ابقى معي ساعود اليك سيد صادق محمد احمد
اذا مشاهدينا اعلن مكتب الامم المتحده
لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه تقليص بعض انشطته
في اجزاء من السودان بسبب القتال الدائري
وفق متحدث باسم المكتب
واوضح ايضا كذلك ان المعارك الحاليه ادت
الى اعاقه العمليات الانسانيه مضطرهم الى
هذا القرار مؤكدا ان الامم المتحده ملتزمه
بمواصله تقديم المساعده لشعب السودان
خلال اتصالاتنا علمنا ان هناك عائلات في
الخرطوم لم تغادر منازلها منذ اكثر من
ثمانيه ايام والحركه بشكل عام في العاصمه
محدوده جدا يجب ان يكون هناك احترام لهدنه
وقف اطلاق النار من قبل الجيش والدعم
السريع ايضا ساعدنا بنجاح عمليات الاجلاء
للاجانب وعليه ندعو المجتمع الدولي الى
الاستمرار ببذل الجهود وحث السودان على
احلال السلام والسماح للفرق الانسانيه
بالعمل خاصه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
والمتطوعين الذين يتعرضون لخطر كبير هناك
نداءات لحمايه المدنيين وفراقنا التي ظلت
عالقه في مكانها تفاديا للقصف تحدثنا مع
المسؤولين في جنيف والسودان للمساعده في
اعاده العمل في المستشفيات وتوفير المياه
والكهرباء
اعربته منظمه الصحه العالميه عن قلقها بعد
11 يوما من القتال في السودان واكدت ان
المنظمه تعمل مع شركائها لاعاده مستشفيات
الخرطوم للعمل
نحن قلقون جدا بعد 11 يوما من القتال في
السودان وحتى الساعه لا يوجد اي تطور لوقف
بوادر القتال ما يزيد من التحديات
الانسانيه المشكله الاساسيه التي نواجهها
هي العجز في وجود المواد الغذائيه والطبيه
وغيرها كما ارتفعت الاسعار بشكل كبير ايضا
ننسقه مع الهلال الاحمر المصري والجمعيات
الاخرى لدعم جميع المحتاجين في البلاد وفي
الخرطوم العائلات عالقه في منازلها
بانتظار الاجلاء نعمل ايضا مع الهلال
الاحمر السوداني والدولي لضمان استمرار
العمل في اكثر من 60 مستشفى وتزويدها
بالمواد الطبيه
هذا وتتواصل حركه نزوح المواطنين من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم الى ولايات
البلاد الاخرى وتشهد العاصمه حركه سفر
ناشطه او نشطه عبر حافلات وباصات في اتجاه
بعض الولايات كالبحر الاحمر والجزيره وقد
تراوحت اسعار التذاكر بين 20 الى 50 الف
جنيه سوداني بعدما كانت لا تتخطى
العشرين الف جنيه قبل اندلاع الاشتباكات
[موسيقى]
من لندن ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي خالد
العيسى السيد خالد مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه الحيه والمباشره
للعربيه اريد السؤال اولا عن ما اتخذته
ولايه شمال كردوفان
بالحظر الجزئي ليلا هل هي خطوه اتت في
وقتها ام تاخرت كما ذكر ضيفنا قبل قليل
تحيه لك ولمشاهديكم الكرام في الواقع ربما
كانت عمليات السجال تجري على قدم وساق بين
المكونين العسكري ممثلا في القوات المسلحه
وبعض منتسبي الدعم السريع خلال الايام
الماضيه وبالتاكيد هذه الخطوه تاتي في
سياق تمشيط المدينه يعني التاكيد على
تامين من كل النواحي خاصه وان المدينه ظلت
حتى قبيل هذه العمليه تشهد بعض يعني
التفلتات الامنيه في الاطراف الجنوبيه
الغربيه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
وبالتالي انا اعتقد انها ربما خطوه مهمه
تزيد من التمتين عمليه الامن في المدينه
المعطيات التي فرضت في الواقع الامني في
السودان بعد 15 ابريل هي عمليه جاد مفاجئه
بكل ما تحمل الكلمه من معان وبالتالي يعني
الامور تترتب رويدا رويدا وبالتاكيد هذه
خطوه في سياق الاتجاه الصحيح وان كانت
تاخرت بعض الشيء ولكن ربما هناك ضرورات
امنيه اقتضت هل تتكرر هذه الحاله في
الخرطوم برايك سيد خالد
الخرطوم شهدت منذ ليله البارحه يعني بعض
الاستقرار والهدوء ولكن عدد الاشياء الى
ما هو عليه الان من سجال وغزف وحركه حرب
في بعض الاحياء والشاهد ان قوات الدعم
السريع بدات تتحرك في عدد من موقع عدد من
المواقع في الخرطوم وهذا يلوم على ان هناك
رغبه مبيته في استغلال فكره
وقف اطلاق النار لتمتين المواقع وتحقيق
اختراعات وعلمنا ايضا ان هناك رتل ربما
يتحرك من منطقه في غرب السودان ولكن
القوات المسلحه في بيانا يعني يوضح اوضحت
انها تتابع هذا العراق
هو كان حصري تج في مراحل سابقه في الايام
الماضيه كانت المعارك مشتده وكان الناس
ربما في بيوتهم لكن الان في بعض الاحياء
في الخرطوم يعني تعيش حاله من الاستقرار
التام في ام درمان في منطقه الكلاك
لشاهدته فيديوهات واستمعت الى بعض
الغباء والمعارف ان الامور في بعض المناطق
هادئه ولكن وسط الخرطوم هو لا يزال يحتاج
الى يعني بعض التجديد الامني حتى تنتهي
هذه المعركه طيب
لكن تم خرق هذه الخدود الهدنه طرف هذا
النزاع يتهمان بعضهم البعض بانه
بان الطرف الاخر هو من خلق هذه الهدنه
وابتدا بالخرق هل هذا يعني بان الصراع لن
يحسم الا بشكل عسكري
وان لا فائده من اي هدنه لانها او مؤقته
حتى لو كانت وبانها لن تطبق ابدا على
الارض والحسم العسكري اصبح اقوى من اي
هدنه تعلن لا توقيتا ولا حسما
بالطبع الخيار المفضل لدى كل ابناء الشعب
السوداني ان تتوقف يعني يتوقف اطلاق النار
وان تتم هدنه دائمه تسمح بمرور المساعدات
الانسانيه والطبيه للمحتاجين في الخرطوم
وفتح ممرات امنه للذين تم يعني اعتقالهم
قهرا في منازله في عدد كبير من الاحياء
واطلاق صراح الاسره هذه جزئيه مهمه هذه
تمنيات كل الشعب السوداني ولكن بالواقع
العسكري الذي نشهده ان هناك رغبه جامعه
لدى قوات الدعم السريع للاستفاده من اي
لحظه هدوء لتحقق مكاسب على الارض في
السجان العسكري وهذا امر مرفوض بالتاكيد
لكن
المنطق يقول في هذه اللحظه ان قوات الدعم
السريع عليها ان تعيد النظر في ان واقعه
الامن وامكانيات العسكريه في ليله 14 15
ابريل
قياسا بما هو عليه الحاله الان هي فقدت
90% من قوه العسكريه وبالتالي لا تستطيع
ان تحدث نصر على ارض المعركه لاسيما ان
الشعب السوداني الان يقف وما يزال وبق وه
شديده شهاده اليوم مواكب في منطقه كرري
تاييده للقوات المسلحه وفي عدد من المدن
هناك التفاف الشعبي والتلاحم جماهير الضخم
غير مسبوق في السودان في تاريخ السودان مع
المؤسسه العسكريه في الجيش
من القدره العسكريه او القدره البشريه
هي بكل تاكيد هناك خسائر كبيره انا لا
يعني لا اريد ان اذكر ارقام وليست هي يعني
علامه لو كانت 90%
مدعاه للحزن
انا دائما اقول ان مثل هذه المعارك
الكبيره يعني حتى هناك تسويق خاطئه لبعض
المفاهيم فكره ان قوات الدعم السريع سيطرت
على بعض المواقع الاستراتيجيه في الخرطوم
فيكترا خاطئه تماما انا زرت هذه المواقع
المذكوره جميعا الخصر الجمهوري
القياده العامه كنت امور عبر كل يوم في
زياراتي للسودان التلفزيون القومي
السوداني هذه الموائع كانت قوات الحراسه
فيها هي من الدعم السريع بامتياز خاصه
المؤسسه مؤسسه التلفزه والاذاعه هذه
الوحده الحمايه في اقوى الدعم السريع منذ
11 ابريل 2019 اذا هي لم تحقق اي اختراق
امني على صعيد العمل العسكري بل هي كانت
في هذه المواقع
واصدرت فيديوهات باعتبار انها احتلت هذه
المواقع لم تحتل هي موجوده اصلا منذ 2019
اذا هي لم تحقق اي وكاتب عسكريه نحن نريد
لهؤلاء الذين هم ابناء وطننا والذين هم
يعني نصفنا الاخر بكل تاكيد وهم يدافعون
عنا الشعب الصحباني لا نريد لهم التهلك
نريد لهم ان يحكم صوت العقل
يجلس الى كلمه سواء نريد لهم ان يكونوا
عناصر فاعله في القوات المسلحه صدرت
مراسيم دستوريه تستوعبهم داخل قوات الشعب
المسلحه التي هي القوات المسلحه داخل حرس
الحدود لماذا يرفضون لماذا تدرسون في فكره
الشعب السوداني يرفضها من اقل الطفل الى
اكبر كال يقفون صفا واحدا متينا خلف الجيش
السوداني اذا ما الفائده فلنفترض انهم
الان اضغط البرهان واستطاعوا ان يحتلوا
القياده العامه ويصدر بيان اول الشعب
السوداني سيسقطهم لا يرغب في وجود ماليزيا
ان تحكم الشعب السوداني هي الان منذ ان
صدرت قرارات حل الدعم السريع تصبح الان
مليشيات بحكم القانون السوداني والدولي
والعالمي لا توجد قوه مسلحه بعد قرارات
القائد العام الذي هو يقود المؤسسه
العسكريه قرارات صريحه
في الجيش سعودي ستبقى معي في يعني ثنايا
هذه التغطيه السعودي اليك مره
اخرى اذن مشاهدينا ومتابعه لعمليات
الاجلاء تستمر ايضا هذه العمليات في ميناء
شرقي السودان لليوم الخامس على التوالي
عمليات واجلاء لمئات من رعايه الدول
العربيه والاسيويه والاوروبيه عبر الجو
والبحر حيث تابعت العربيه مراحل اجراءات
اجلاء مئات من رعايه دوله الهند فيما
ينتظرون نحو الفين من رعايه الدول وممثل
البعثات الدبلوماسيه وموظفي الامم المتحده
ايضا تكمله اجراءات اجلائهم من السودان
عبر الميناء خلال الساعات المقبله
هذا هو الميناء الشمالي بمدينه بورسودان
بولايه البحر الاحمر بشرق السودان هنا
تستمر عمليه الاجلاء لمئات من رعايه الدول
العربيه والاوروبيه والاسيويه التي بدات
من الخرطوم العاصمه برا الى شرق السودان
ومنها عبر البحر الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبعدها يغادرون الى دولهم عمليه
الاجلاء تمضي تحت اشراف كامل من قبل الجيش
السوداني عبر مسارين بحري وجوي وكانت
العديد من الدول العربيه والاسيويه
والاوروبيه قد شرعت في التنسيق مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في الترتيب لاجلاء
رعاياها خلال الساعات الماضيه
في هذه المرحله من مراحل عمليه الاجلاء
التي بدات هنا في شرق السودان يتم الوصول
الى هذه المرحله وهي مرحله الاستوثاق من
الاوراق الثبوتيه ومن الجوازات هنا تقوم
الشرطه السودانيه ممثله في اداره الجوازات
والهجره بالتعرف على كافه الاوراق
الثبوتيه وجوازات السفر تمهيدا
لنقلهم عبر الباخره الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومنها الى بقيه دولهم هنا
292 من رعايه دوله الهند بالسودان اكملوا
اجراءات مغادرتهم واجلائهم من مدينه
بورسودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومنها الى دولتهم فيما ينتظر اخرون
استكمال اجراءاتهم لمغادره البلاد خلال
الساعات المقبله نزار البغداوي لقناتي
العربيه والحدث الميناء الشمالي مدينه
بورسودان شرقيه السودان
اذا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور
الخاصه التي حصلت عليها العربيه لعمليات
الاجلاء الفرنسيه من السودان نحو جيبوتي
كان الرئيس ماكرون قد اعلن بان فرنسا اجلت
538 شخصا من السودان بينهم
فرنسيين اعلن ايضا كذلك عن اصابه احد
الجنود الفرنسيين خلال عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان ايضا قبل قليل كانت قد اعلنت
اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه بان عمليه الاجلاء
من السودان نحو جيبوتي قد انتهت اذن هذه
صور كما ذكرنا قبل قليل صور خاصه
للعربيه اثناء نقل بعض طبعا المعدات
والمركبات ايضا كذلك
اخلاء السفاره ربما الفرنسيه تماما في
الخرطوم ونقل كل العاملين والموظفين
والبعث الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه
واجلائهم تماما من السودان نحو جيبوتي عبر
احدى الطائرات
النقل او الشحن الكبيره كما نشاهد الان
على الشاشه امامنا اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه
كانت قد ذكرت ايضا بان هناك
فرقاطه فرنسيه ستظل قرب بورت سودان لتساعد
في عمليات الاجلاء الامميه اذا اركان
الجيش الفرنسيه كانت قد اعلنت انتهاء
العمليه وقالت بان عمليه الاجراء الفرنسيه
من السودان شملت احدى واربعين جنسيه
بالاضافه ايضا لتصريحات الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون والذي قال بان فرنسا نجحت
باجلاء 538 شخصا من الخرطوم اعلن عن اصابه
احد الجنود الفرنسيين ايضا
خلال هذه العمليات
استطعت مشاهدينا كاميرا العربيه بعضا من
ردود فعل من تم اجلائهم عبر معبر ارجين
البري اورجين البري بين مصر والسودان
والله كان طويله طويله جدا هي الرحله كانت
كلها مخاطر وكذا
وضارب شديد حاصل هناك
في ضرب في الطريق
السودانيه مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان احمد
مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه الجديد ايضا
لديك احمد حول عمليات الاجلاء في هذا
المعبر كيف تتم الاجراءات ايضا
نعم هناك استمرار في عمليه الاجلاء كما
ذكرت لك على مدار الساعه يعني الساعه
الماضيه يعني يبدو ان الوضع كان هادئ ربما
في انتظار وصول وفود جديده للخروج من
بوابه هذا المعبر بعد انتهاء الاجراءات
يعني كنا قد تحدثنا مع بعض الذين قد خرجوا
خلال الساعات الماضيه والذين تحدثوا بانها
كانت رحله طويله وشاقه وانهم يعني يشعرون
اخيرا بالامان بعد الوصول الى المعبر
المصري ربما في انتظارهم رحله طويله ايضا
للوصول الى مدينه اسوان التي تبعد حوالي
اكثر من 400 كيلو متر يعني حوالي خمس
ساعات بالحافلات والسيارات هذه الحافلات
التي تنتظر ربما خروج هذه الوفود حتى الان
يعني لا يوجد اي ارقام دقيقه او احصائيات
دقيقه لان الارقام تتغير على مدار الساعه
ولكن مع مساء كل يوم يكون هناك بيان مفصل
من وزاره الخارجيه المصريه حول اجمالي ما
تم اجلائهم من مصريين او من سودانيين من
من المنافذ المصريه او حتى من خلال
الطائرات المصريه العسكريه التي تذهب الى
الخرطوم بشكل يومي لنقل الكثير من
العالقين المصريين يعني هناك بالفعل عمل
لربما يعتبره البعض على قدم وساق لمساله
انهاء وتسهيل خروج
المصريين والسوريين وايضا الرعايه الدول
الاجنبيه فجر اليوم التقيد بسفير جورجيا
الذي جاء بنفسه للاشراف على عمليه
الاجلاء كان هناك ايضا ممثلين من الملحق
العسكري من اوكرانيا ايضا من دول اخرى مثل
ايطاليا خلال الايام الماضيه كل هذه
الامور يتم العمل فيها وايضا يتم التنسيق
مع الجانب السوداني لتوفير ممرات امنه
للوصول من يريد ان يصل الى الحدود المصريه
من خلال الحافلات ومن ثم سيكون هناك ايضا
كما ذكرت لك رحله اخرى الى مدينه اسوان
اغلب من التقيتهم من سودانيين اكدوا انهم
سينكسون لا لفتره هناك الكثير من الاصدقاء
والاهالي والاقارب في اسوان هناك اقتراب
في العادات ربما ايضا هناك ايجار البيوت
خلال المرحله المقبله سيكون ارخص كثيرا من
التوجه الى القاهره بعد المصريين والاجانب
سيتوجهون الى المطار حيث ان هناك كثافه
كبيره جدا في حجز الطائرات والحافلات
والقطرات التي تتوجه من اسوان الى القاهره
خلال الايام الماضيه ومن المتوقع ان تستمر
هذه الكثافه خلال ايضا الايام المقبله حتى
تتضح الصوره بعد ما التقيتهم سالتهم حول
خطواتهم المقبله اكدوا انهم سينتظرون
لمراقبه المشهد لا احد يستطيع ان ياخذ
قرارا بالعوده مره اخرى او خلال ايام
مقبله الا حينما يكون هناك تاكد من فعلا
هناك التزام بوقف اطلاق النار وبان هناك
هدنه وبان هناك تطور في المشهد السياسي
يسمح لهم بخوض هذه الرحله التي اعتبروها
من اكثر الرحلات التي خاضوا فيها ربما
يعني رعبا خلال
السنوات الماضيه طيب احمد ايضا اريد
السؤال هل هناك تقدير لاعداد من وصلوا الى
هذا المعبر حتى هذه اللحظه هل هناك ايضا
تقدير معرفه للجنسيات ايضا من لجا عبر هذا
المعبر من السودان الى مصر
يعني كما ذكرت لك هناك بيان يخرج من
الخارجيه مساء كل يوم ولكن نستطيع ان نقول
بانه حتى الان نحن نتحدث في حدود الالاف
يعني اذا كنت تحدث خلال الايام الماضيه عن
مئات الذين ياتون عن عشرات الحافلات في
الامس كان هناك تقديرات مبدئيه بان الرقم
قد قد اقترب من خمسه او سته الاف من هذا
المعبر لوحده من مصريين وسودانيين ومن
رعايه دول اجنبيه تم اجلائهم بالاضافه
ايضا الى ما يتم من يتم اجلائهم عبر
المطارات كما ذكرت لك هذه الارقام ربما
تبدو مبدئيه وتبدو تدقيق لان هناك ربما
نقطه اخرى هي مساله المساله التدقيق
الامني فيما يتعلق بمن يخرجون هناك من يرى
بان مع توفير التسهيلات كل هذه التسهيلات
من قبل السلطات المصريه خصوصا لكبار السن
والمصابين والاطفال وهو ما شاهد به الكثير
ممن التقيناهم خلال الساعات الماضيه هناك
ايضا مساله التدقيق الامني وهي نقطه هامه
للغايه فيما يتعلق به يعني التعرف على
هويه من جاء كثير منهم قالوا بانهم فقدوا
جوازات سفرهم او فقدوا بخترقتهم خلال
لحظات الهروع هناك بان هذا المشهد هام جدا
ربما لربطه بما حدث من ان هذه المنافذ
البريه كانت وسيله او ملاذا لبعض العناصر
الارهابيه التي حاولت ان تخرج من مصر ابان
ثوره يونيو 2013 وبالتالي هناك عمل خليه
بالفعل كما تعلمنا خليه ازمه يعني تحت
اشراف الرئاسه وفيها عناصر من جميع
الوزارات السياديه لمتابعه هذا الملف
توفير الاحتياجات والتسهيل الاحتياجات تم
التاكيد عليها من خلال توصيات سواء من
دراسه الجمهوريه ومن خلال عدد من الوزارات
ولكن ايضا هناك تنسيق يتم سواء مع الجانب
السوداني من خلال توفير الممرات الامنه او
ايضا من خلال العمل من خلال اعضاء هذه
اللجنه لضمان ان يكون هناك توفير وخروج
للكثير من المواطنين سواء مصريين او
سودانيين باسهل الطرق لاستكمال مسيرتهم
الى مدن المصريه الاخرى اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل التي وفيتنا بها من بعمري
اركيني على الحدود المصريه السودانيه
مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان
اذا دوليا اعلن رئيس الوزراء الياباني
فوميو كيشيدا ان فرنسا نقلت ثمانيه
مواطنين يابانيين من بينهم مسؤولون
بالسفاره واسرهم من قاعده للقوات الجويه
في شمال الخرطوم
في اعقاب اجلاء خمسه واربعين شخصا الليله
الماضيه بطائرات تابعه لقوات الدفاع
تلقينا في وقت مبكر اليوم تقريرا يفيد بان
ثمانيه يابانيين مقيمين في السودان بينهم
مسؤولون بالسفاره واسرهم غادروا من قاعده
وادي سيدنا الجويه الواقعه الشمالي
العاصمه الخرطوم بمساعده فرنسا سنمضي قدما
من خلال المكتب المؤقت الذي اقيم في
جيبوتي سوف نستمر في التواصل عن كذب مع
الدول المعنيه وسنبذل قصارى جهدنا لضمان
سلامه المقيمين اليابانيين في السودان
وتقديم الدعم الضروري
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه على النت ايضا
اجلاء معظم مراعيها في السودان عبر
مجموعات الى الموانئ الحدوديه بالدول
المجاوره وقالت المتحدثه باسم الوزاره
انبكينا لم تتلقى اي تقارير عن سقوط ضحايا
صينيين بالسوداني حتى الان
وفيما يتصل
بعمليات الاجلاء ايضا اعلنت القوات
المسلحه الالمانيه اجلاء حوالي 100 شخص
اخر من السودان بمن فيهم مواطني المانيا
ودول اخرى ليصبح مجموع الاشخاص الذين تم
اجلائه 500 شخص من السودان الى الاردن عبر
5 رحلات منذ بدايه الازمه في السودان
واستمرار الاشتباكات بين القوات المسلحه
وقوات الدعم السريع حسب ما افادت وكاله
الانباء الالمانيه
من جهته اعلن الرئيس الفرنسي صابه
الجنديين فرنسي خلال عمليه الاجلاء من
السودان معلنا اجلاء 538 شخصا من السودان
بينهم 200 وتسعه فرنسيين حتى الان جاء ذلك
خلال تراس ماكرون اجتماع مجلس الدفاعي
والامن الوطني حيث تمت مناقشه تطورات
الاوضاع في السودان
الحكومه البريطانيه بدورها اعلنت بدا
اجلاء راعيها من السودان وذكرت الحكومه ان
طائرات عسكريه بريطانيه ستقلع من مطار
خارج الخرطوم تباعا ومن جانبه قال وزير
خارجيه البريطاني انه لا يمكن اجلاء سوى
حامل جواز السفر البريطاني وافراد اسرهم
مضيفا ان الاولويه ستكون للمرضى او
العائلات التي لديها اطفال او كبار السن
اعود مره اخرى الى لندن والى الصادق محمد
احمد مدير الوكاله الدوليه للتنميه والعون
الانساني مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى سيد
الصادق يعني عمليات الاجلال ربما تابعتها
منذ اكثر من خمسه ايام تسير يعني بشكل
ربما بطيء نوعا ما لكن اريد السؤال عن ما
ستخلفه هذه العمليات عمليات الاجلاء على
السودان انسانيا وكذلك ايضا صحيا هل
يتراجع الدوره ايضا دور المنظمات
الانسانيه ودور الام المتحده ايضا
ومكاتبها الانسانيه في السودان بسبب خروج
كل الاجانب من السودان
من الطبيعي في كل الحالات عندما يكون هناك
ازمات ويكون هناك حروب ان تعمل
تعمد البعثات الدبلوماسيه الى رعاياها حتى
من غير الدبلوماسيه احيانا تلجا بعض الدول
الى رعاياها من المنطقه التي فيها مخاطر
وهذا امر مشروع وطبيعي
الغير مقبول هو من تسبب في هذه اذا لاحظت
ان هذه البعثات الدبلوماسيه لم تفكر في
ادلاء رعاياها الحرب مستمره منذ السبت
الماضي الان حوالي عشره ايام لم يفكروا في
ايجار عاياهم تفكر في دار عليها الا بعد
مرور خمسه ايام ربما على العمليات في
الايام الاولى لم تفكر هذه البعثات في
الادلاء ولكن بسبب اعتداءات الميليشيات
على البعثات الدوراسيه نفسه على مقرها
وشاهدنا البارحه الحادث الموسفه
لمقتل الدبلوماسي المصري في السفاره
المصريه على يد
هذه
الحوادث تلقي بظلال مقاتمه على الوضع
البعثات الدبلوماسيه وعلى الوضع الخارجي
وثقه البعثات اصلا والدول في بقاء رعاياها
يعني تسببت الميليشيات باعتداءاتها على
البعثات الدبلوماسيه وعلى مقر المنظمات
الانسانيه في تعليق عبر المنظمات
الانسانيه اولا بسبب اعتداء على برنامج
الغذاء العالمي وقتل ثلاثه من افراد
برنامج القذاء العالمي وبعدها تم الاعتداء
ايضا على موظف
المنظمه الهجره الدوليه وقتل ايضا في
الابيض الاعتداءات المتكرره على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ومقارنه المنظمات في الخرطوم
وفي مدن السودان الاخرى كل ذلك
عمدت هذه الميليشيات على احراج الحكومه
تعتقد انها بهذه الافعال ستحرج تسببت
تسببت فيما نراه الان من
من اله
وكاله الامم المتحده للهجره كانت قد قالت
بانها رصدت
12 الف لاجئ من السودان عبر الحدود وقالت
بان عمليه النزوح ايضا الى الحدود في
السودان الى الحدود مستمره
برايك اولا هل هذه ارقام دقيقه اذا تحدثنا
عن اثني عشر الف شخص بالاضافه الى عمليات
النزوح الى الحدود الى اين يمكن ان تصل
ارقام النازحين الى الحدود سواء الحدود
الدوليه للسودان او ايضا حتى من الخرطوم
الى ولايات قريبه من العاصمه الخرطوم مثل
الاوبيض اعتقد انك تقصد بهذه الارقام
النازحين على الحدود السودانيه التشاديه
طبعا ما تعلم ان هذه المنطقه منطقه تداخل
قبلي
يوميا حتى في حالات السلم ولا في الحالات
الايام العاديه كان هناك تداخل
وشبه حركه يوميه بين الجانبين هناك اسواق
على المدن الحدوديه وهناك حركه باتجاه
واحد
ايضا ايضا يكون هناك في هذه الفتره ربما
يكون بعض المخاطر يعني ادت بالبعض الى
العبور الحدود ولكن عموما المنطقه ليست
بتلك الخطوره التي كم عليها العاصمه مثلا
بل ليس هناك عمليات الان عسكريه في منطقه
الحدود السودانيه ولكن اعتقد ان المنطقه
التي يمكن ان تشهد بعض ان كانت منطقه
صحراويه التي تشهد عمليات والتي تتوقع ان
تشهد عمليات في الفتره القادمه هي منطقه
الحدود السودانيه الليبيه حيث ان فؤاد كما
واصل التقارير استخباراتيه موثقه والحكومه
تعلم عنها والاستخبارات العسكريه كذلك
تعرف عنها بانزال انزال اسلحه على منطقه
الحدود السودانيه السودانيه الليبيه في في
في قاعده شفروليه التي انشاتها قوات الدعم
السريع
بتنسيقنر واعتقد ان هذه المنطقه هي التي
ستشهد في الفتره المقبله
عمليات عسكريه من قبل الجيش حيث انه تم
رصد
انزال الجوي لهذه الاسلحه على هذه المنطقه
واضح اشكرك جزيل الشكر من لندن مدير
الوكاله الدوليه للتنميه والعمل الانساني
الصادق محمد احمد
اذا وفي خضم عمليه الاجلاء هذه هو منذ
اربعه ايام تلعب المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دورا انسانيا رائدا في اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب في مناطق القتال في السودان
السعوديه خصصت قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
في جده لاستقبال رعايه الدول قبل ترتيب
نقلهم الى بلدانهم في وقت لاحق
[موسيقى]
هذا واعلن وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان في تغريده على تويتر ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ستتواصل مع
الاشقاء في السودان لتامين ممرات امنه
لاجلاء رعايه الدول الصديقه والشقيقه كما
اكد الامير فيصل بن فرحان مواصله المملكه
عمليه اجلاء رعايه الدول التي تقدمت بطلب
مساعده مواطنيها ونقلهم لاماكن امنه
حاليا اول شيء هو الشكر الجزيل للقياده
والشعب السعودي على الجهود اللي بدلت في
سبيل اجلال الرعايه الليبيين 104 شخص طبعا
طلقنا من يوم الخميس صباحا الى يوم الجمعه
رحله طويله لمده 25 ساعه الى مدينه
بورسودان وبعد ذلك بقينا ثلاثه ايام حتى
تمت عمليه
الاجلاء المملكه العربيه السعوديه على
قدموا لنا طلعونا وجابونه وقعدونا الطريق
كنسل السومه وما قصروا معنا بشيء ما في
خدمه طلبناها ما كانوا موفرينها فالحمد
لله تم الاتفاق مع السفاره اللبنانيه
والسفيره اللبنانيه عملت اتصالاتها مع
السعوديه مشكورين كثير على كل شيء قدمتوه
من جهد نحن بنشكركم كثير من قلبنا
الى لندن وينضم الينا من هناك مره اخرى
الكاتب الصحفي خالد العيسر سيد خالد مرحبا
بك معي من جديد في هذه التغطيه للشان
السوداني دعنا ننتقل الى ما يخص
الى ما يخص الامور العسكريه والاستراتيجيه
ايضا في الخرطوم السيطره بعد 11 يوما كيف
تقرا الخارطه العسكريه في العاصمه الخرطوم
هل كان متوقعا ما يحدث اليوم بان الجيش لم
يستطع حسم المساله في الخرطوم حتى الان
بالتاكيد الخبراء العسكريين ربما يكون
لديهم المعرفه الكافيه بعنصر المفاجاه
والمباغه التي الذي مارسته قوات الدعم
السريع اذا افترضنا ان هناك قوات غازيه من
خارج السودان وصارت نحو العاصمه الخرطوم
هنا يمكن ان نوجه الانتقاد للمؤسسه
العسكري بانها كانت ضعيفه بعض الشيء ولكن
عندما نتحدث عن قوات هي موجوده في متوغلة
في الوجدان السوداني بكل مساحات الرؤى
الجغرافيه في كل المدن بل الشيء المؤسف
انها كانت تؤتمن على مراكز مهمه جدا البنك
المركزي التلفزيون القصر الجمهوري للقياده
العامه حتى وسمح الان تتمدد احتلت كل
القواعد العسكريه في الخرطوم بالاطراف
الثلاثه في المدن الثلاث وكانت موجوده في
الولايات اذا نظرنا الى هذه المعادله
قياسا بما فعلوا الجيش في هذه اليوم سنجد
ان هناك يعني نوع من الاعجاز نوع من
الخيال ان يتمكن الجيش السوداني من فرض
سطوته وسلطته وقوته على ارض الواقع في كل
ولايات السودان ما عدا جيوب صغيره في
نتحدث عن يعني اتباع اساليب لا تتصل
بالقانون بصله الدعم السريعي الان يعني
هذه الجمل موجوده توجد مص الاحياء بين
السكان وبين الاطفال والنساء بل تخرج
المواطنين من بيوتهم وتخرج المواطنين من
المستشفيات المرضى هذا اسلوب الجيش
السوداني كما ذكرنا مرارا هو جيش تربع على
عقيده عسكريه محترمه للغايه ومدرسه تعلم
للاجيال انه لا يعتدي على السكان في المدن
وكان بامكانهم يحسم هذه المعركه ولم
يستخدم قدراته العسكريه نحن لا ننحاز نحن
نصوب اللوم للجهه التي اخطات والجهه التي
اخطات يقوى الدعم السريع والشاهد المواكب
التي تخرج وانا اتحدث اليك الان وهناك
موكب ضخم في النيل الابيض كوستي انا لا
ادري لماذا وسائل الاعلام لا تنقل مثل هذه
المواكب وهناك موكب خرج في دنقله قبل ايام
وموكب اخر في مدينه العويد وموكب اليوم
صباحا في كالوري هذا هو الشعب الذي تريد
ان ترسخه الديمقراطيه اقوات الدعم السريع
باسمه هو هذه القوات الان يرفض سلوكه الذي
لا يمت للعقيده العسكريه باي صله الجيش
السوداني قادر على حسب هذه المعركه وانا
استطيع ان اؤكد لك ذلك وهو الجيش السوداني
الان لم يعد 200 الف جندي ولا سلاح
الطيران ولا مدفعيه ولا
سلاح البحريه الجيش السوداني الان 40
مليون سوداني على قد رجل واحد سيقدمون
شهيد تلو الشهيد الى ان تتعرض الخرطوم او
تستجيب وقت الدعم السريع للنداءات التي
نتمنى ان تستجيب لها وتحكم صوت العقل لما
يفيد السودان هذا هو الجيش السوداني الجيش
السوداني لم يعد قوات يعني
تاخذ اجور ورواتب الجيش السوداني والشعب
السوداني الان الذي قال كلمه واضحه جدا
وانا اتمنى ان تسلط وسائر الاعلام يعني
وسائل لتنقل مثل هذه المشاهد حتى وصل
الرساله لغايه الدعم السريع ان الشعب
السوداني يرفض هذا السلوك ولا يقف معها في
هذه العمليه العسكريه نحن في العربيه ننقل
الصور من كل الولايات السودانيه ومن كل
المدن ايضا حتى السودانيه والتغطيتنا
شامله طبعا لما يحدث في السودان على كل
المستويات السياسيه والعسكريه وكذلك ايضا
حتى الانسانيه
العربيه لانك يعني
نعم نعم صحيح انا اعرف ولكن اتحدث انا عن
تغطيه العربيه هنا بانها شامله وموسعه لكل
ما يحدث في السودان على مدى 24 ساعه منذ
احد عشر يوما شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن
الكاتب الصحفي خالد الاعسر
السودان هي النقطه الاكثر تماسا مع الدول
الافريقيه السودان دوله جوار لسبع دول
نتعرف على هذه الدول المحاذيه والممرات
البريه والبحريه السودان
جمهوريه السودان محاطه بعده دول من ثلاثه
اتجاهات تحدها سبعه دول شمالا وغربا
وجنوبا مع تعدد المعابر البريه والممرات
المائيه لها الجاره الشماليه مصر تتشارك
مع السودان بحدود طولها
1276 كيلومترا في منطقه صحراويه بشكل عام
وبها معبران رئيسيه هما اشكيت وارجين
ليبيا على الجهه الاخرى تربطها بالسودان
حدود تمتد ل 3002 كيلومترا في بيئه تتنوع
تضاريسها ما بين صحراء وجبال وسهول يوجد
معبر واحد بين الدولتين هو العوينات قرب
المثلث الحدودي بين الدولتين ومصر
الى الغرب من السودان شريط حدودي مع تشاد
طوله
1403 كيلومترات ومعبر رئيسي يربط بين
مدينتي الجنينه في دارفور وادري في تشاد
اكثر حدود للسودان تربطها بجمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى وتقل عن 200 كيلومتر مع
معبر وحيد هو ام دافوج بالقرب من هذه
الحدود نجد اطول حدود للسودان وهي مع دوله
جنوب السودان طولها 1900 كيلو متر وبها
عشره معابر حدوديه متفق عليها بين
الدولتين الا انه لم يتم افتتاح كل هذه
المعابر في جنوب شرق البلاد تشترك السودان
مع اثيوبيا بسبعمائه واربعه واربعين مترا
من الحدود مع معبر رئيسي هو الفشقه سابع
الدول المحاذيه للسودان اريتريا مع حدود
طولها 605 كيلو مترات ومعبر وحيد هو طوكر
وفي الجهه الشرقيه من السودان وممراتها
البحريه على البحر الاحمر فهي تضم مينا
اين رئيسيين هما ميناء ابورتسودان وسواكن
حسن غوليد العربيه
احد عشر يوما مر الصراع فيه بتداعيات
كارثيه على الاقتصاد السوداني اقتصاد
مهترئ بالاساس رغم غنى السودان بالموارد
الطبيعيه كالذهب ومع توقف مطار الخرطوم عن
العمل خسرت الخزينه السودانيه نصف قيمه
صادراتها فيما سعر الصرف انزلق لادنى
مستوياته
عكاز الاقتصاد السوداني هوت فالاخير كان
متكئا على حافه الانهيار حتى قبل بدء صراع
الجنرلين لي الذراع الاقتصاديه تمثل بخروج
مطار الخرطوم عن الخدمه اولا ما افقد
خزينه الدوله اكثر من 50% من صادرات
البلاد اي صادرات الذهب المقدره بملياري
دولار توقف عمل المطار عطل خمسه في المئه
من اجمالي الصادرات والواردات فيما طالت
معدلات التضخم عتبه الستين في المئه ارقام
وصفها مراقبون بغير الدقيقه مضيفين ان
التضخم فوق ذلك بكثير نسبه مماثله قدرت
عند قياس معدل الفقر والذي يتجاوز 60 في
المئه فاكثر من اربعين فيلما من
السودانيين قابعون في خانه البطاله اما
سعر صرف العمله فتدهور بشكل كبير خلال
الفتره الانتقاليه وايام الصراع الاولى
مسجلا انخفاضا قياسيا امام الدولار ليصل
الى 600 جنيه حاليا هذه الارقام قد تصبح
خجوله اذا ما اتسعت رقعه الصراع الجغرافيه
الضيقه والمنحصره بالخرطوم حاليا ففي حين
توقف مطار الخرطوم الا ان الموانئ لا تزال
تعمل سته عشره ولايه سودانيه لم تتاثر
بالنزاع حتى اللحظه بينها الولايات
الشرقيه مثل القضارف وكسلا وبورتسودان
وولايه نهر النيل وهي تؤمن الطرق من موقع
الموانئ الى العاصمه
لكن في حال تمددت رقعه الحرب سيتاثر
الاحتياطي المحلي الاجمالي وسيتفاقم
التضخم وتنهار قيمه العمله اكثر واكثر
فخمسه وثمانون في المئه من حجم الصادرات
والواردات الكليه البالغه 15 مليار دولار
سنويا تتم عبر الموانئ البحريه في
بورتسودان والبحر الاحمر فيما العشره في
المئه المتبقيه تشق طريقها الى الجاره
المصريه عبر مينا اي ارجين وشكات
ومع استمرار القتال بين الطرفي الصراع في
السودان برزت اتهاماته لمجموعه باجنار
الروسيه بتزويد قوات الدعم السريع
بالاسلحه اتهامات نفتها الاخيره جمله
وتفصيلا في وقت حذرت اطراف اوروبيه من
تغلغل روسي في الساحه السودانيه
كلما اشتعلت نيران المواجهات المسلحه
وبرزت بؤره توتر في اي نقطه من العالم
طفائل السطح الحديث عن مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه الاشتباكات الجاريه في السودان لا
تخرج عن هذه القاعده اتهامات لمجموعه
فاجنر بتزويد قوه الدعم السريع بصواريخ
ارض جو كانت مخزنه في افريقيا الوسطى
للمساعده في قتالها ضد الجيش السوداني
وزير خارجيه فنلندا قال ان ثمه مخاطر من
ان تستفيد مجموعه فاجنر من الازمه الراهنه
على الاتحاد الاوروبي فعل المزيد فيما
يتعلق بالوضع في السودان ليس من العدل ان
يغادر جميع الاجانب البلاد في هذه الظروف
اذا غادرنا فاننا نترك ايضا بعض المجال
لقوات فاجنر وروسيا للعب في هذه اللعبه
قوات الدعم السريع بقياده حميدتي نفت
الاتهامات جمله وتفصيلا فهي ادعاءه خاليه
من الصحه وجزء من حرب المعلومات والاخبار
المزيفه التي تشن عليها تقول الدعم السريع
نرفض رفضا القاطعا مزاعم تورطنا مع مجموعه
فاجنر في الصراع الحالي في السودان
الازمه في السودان تستمر في التعمق مع
مرور الايام الاحداث على الارض تنذر بتفجر
الوضع اكثر فاكثر مع امكانيه تدخل قوى
خارجيه في الصراع كما حدث في مناطق مختلفه
من العالم فالتاريخ يصر دائما على ان يعيد
نفسه بلال الوجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات